[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando a humanidade começou a tomar
consciência de sua própria existência
teve algo que sempre acompanhou o que
foi incrível noturno com diversos
pontinhos luminosos e que trazia para a
gente uma indagação de como que a
humanidade se conectava com aquilo
foram em torno de 70 mil anos de
histórias criadas narrativas contadas
pra gente conseguir se aproximar dessa
imensidão que habita sobre nossas
cabeças e não faz mais do que 70 anos
que de fato conseguimos concretizar a
idéia de criar tecnologias pra ir até o
espaço
a pergunta que eu faço pra vocês é quem
é que nunca sonhou de fato que poderá
evitar trabalhar ou apenas tocar o
espaço e hoje eu venho contar essa
história pra vocês de como a gente vem
revolucionando essa interação da
comunidade com espaço e como minha vida
de certa forma está ligado a isso então
eu já respondendo à pergunta sonhei com
isso e quando tinha seis anos de idade
tive sorte dos meus pais não levaram
para conhecer o cabo canaveral na
flórida centro de lançamento da nasa
voltei com dez anos e lá comecei a
sentir aquele chamado que um dia
realmente queria trabalhar com espaço
eu cresci na década de 80 foi uma década
recheado de sessão da tarde pipoca
falando sobre espaço e aquilo nunca
passei na minha vida acho que nunca
maduro e se ao ponto de querer fazer
outra coisa na minha vida que não fosse
trabalhar no espaço e isso acabou
culminando na eu me formar como
engenheiro espacial e 2014 ajudar uma
equipe para usar uma sonda e um cometa
foi a primeira vez que a humanidade fez
isso e eu com muito orgulho digo que foi
o único brasileiro a participar disso
mas ao mesmo tempo me questionar porque
não temos mais brasileiros participando
desse tipo de empreitadas resolvi voltar
pro brasil comecei algo a diria muito
ambicioso que é fazer uma sonda
brasileira para mandar pra lua com
conexão com a cidade de são carlos a
gente fez o anúncio foi formalizado na
missão garatéia que essa missão que vai
até a lua em 2022
aqui na cidade de são carlos ea última
foto demonstra eu já no ano passado
junto com a esposa no mesmo lugar no
cabo canaveral lance
na minha própria carga para o espaço
então hoje em dia tem uma história para
contar
dentro da área espacial e isso permitiu
e vislumbrar uma economia uma
oportunidade que vai muito além dessa
quem está acostumado a escutar e ao tal
do new space que eu vim falar pra vocês
um pouco sobre isso hoje não quero
começar a apresentação fazendo alguns
dados interessantes
primeiro queria falar pra vocês de um
isótopo do do hélio que é o hélio 3 e e
solta por me permite criar energia
através dele fazer fusão nuclear mas
infelizmente não tem naturalmente no
planeta terra não consiga utilizar ele
de maneira natural aqui eu só consigo
fabricar ele é muito custoso fabricar
mas eu tenho mudança no sistema solar
esse elemento então a superfície da lua
por exemplo está recheado de gaia 03 e
desculpa de do exótico o hélio-3 e
júpiter tem 20% da constituição da sua
atmosfera de hélio 3
então a gente tem uma mudança energética
muito grande na lua e em outros lugares
do sistema solar
só para vocês terem uma idéia eu trouxe
alguns dados que a gente comparar se eu
pegar todo o hélio-3 que existe na
superfície lunar e trouxessem isso pra
terra eu tenho 250 anos de energia limpa
para ser utilizada aqui no nosso planeta
essa economia a cada ano geraria um
contorno de um trilhão de dólares por
ano de economia energética do nosso
planeta então você já vê um grande
potencial ainda não explorado em um
pouquinho além da lua
falando um pouco nos asteróides a gente
tem asteróides como o caso aí do psi que
16 psique que ele sozinho tem 10 4
milhões de dólares de metais valiosos
embutidos nele
se você pegar todos cinturão de
asteróides que existe entre marte e
júpiter e dividir esses metais valiosos
para cada ser humano que existe vivo
hoje em dia dar em torno de 100 bilhões
de dólares por pessoa viva na terra
esse potencial existe é um fato ainda
não alcançado mas temos diversas
empresas agora ao redor do mundo
começando a pesquisar meios de acessar
essa economia
o interessante é que não consigo estimar
pra vocês não quero fazer aqui um
exercício de futurologia
em quanto tempo a gente alcançar isso
talvez seja 10 50 100 ou talvez a gente
nunca consiga de fato minera asteróides
ou coletar hélio-3 na lua e júpiter e
saturno mas a idéia é que isso existe
impulsiona uma grande economia
nessa direção de que a gente pode chegar
lá e fazer esse tipo de coisa acontecer
mas a história da conquista espacial
passou longe disso a gente não tinha
essa percepção até pouco tempo e aí
contando um pouco da história de como a
exploração espacial de fato começou ela
começou aqui numa disputa de geopolítica
onde tínhamos rússia estados unidos
competindo para ver quem poderia
alcançar primeiro o espaço
então durante quase 60 anos a busca que
a gente tinha era busca de tocar o
espaço e provar para os outros que a
gente era capaz de tocar primeiro
isso obviamente funcionou por bastante
tempo mas demandou um espelho muito
grande de dinheiro para conseguir fazer
esse toque no espaço e também acabou
criando de certa forma algumas situações
como é o caso aqui do buran para quem
não conhece apresenta que o ônibus
espacial russo que a rússia investiu
bilhões e bilhões de dólares na época
pra voar oficialmente apenas uma vez com
esse lançador porquê porque é um projeto
tão elaborado tecnológicamente falando
que tornou inviável economicamente
falando de se colocar em prática isso
ocorreu mesmo tempo ônibus espacial
só que os americanos leitões de terem
gasto tanto e não sabe como contar com a
população que aquilo gastava muito
dinheiro mantiveram ao longo de quase 30
anos vôos de ônibus espaciais
gastando bastante dinheiro estados
unidos e permitindo que outros países
principalmente é da europa ocidental e
rússia que dominassem a frente comercial
de acesso ao espaço porque seus modelos
lançamento eram muito baratos e quando a
gente usa é essa maneira geral política
de de gea local recursos e procurar
resultados a gente começa a falar de
acesso democrático ao espaço
então sem imaginar que até hoje em dia
tem um pouquinho mais do que 190 países
apenas 72 países declaram algum tipo de
exercício junto ao espaço e essa
declaração de exercício
o espaço pode ser um país do leste
europeu que tem um microssatélite óptima
e tem uma pessoa única ali fazendo toda
a parte operacional de satélite
o brasil está incluso nesse 72 países de
72 apenas 14 consegue colocar sua
própria carga no espaço é uma questão de
soberania que é muito importante e
poucos países dominam a tecnologia de
colocar sua própria carga no espaço
desses 14 apenas seis países conseguem
fazer missões completas e complexas como
missões interplanetárias missões de
exploração de outros corpos celestes e
apenas três países a china rússia
estados unidos conseguem colocar ser
humano no espaço
então fica meio claro que a gente não
tem um acesso democrático ao espaço hoje
em dia mesmo que em atividades
secundárias e terciárias provenientes do
espaço cheguei no globo como um todo mas
a maior parte dos países não consegue
decidir como querem fazer uso do espaço
que está sobre a nossa própria cabeça
então isso tem que ser mudado né isso
novos países buscam dentro de novos
modelos de negócio
então a idéia principal que a gente tem
hoje em dia é como criar um modelo de
negócio sustentável que tem um impacto
social e que faça uso de tecnologias
baseadas no espaço e é isso eu dou o
nome de new space
a idéia do new space é tudo bem não quer
dizer que não sou mais independente do
governo o governo ainda é um ator muito
importante e se você pega a história por
exemplo do romance com a spacex o maior
consumidor o cliente do do foguete
romance que é o próprio governo
mas o romance que nunca perguntou o
governo americano se ele queria que
fizesse um foguete que decolasse e
pousasse na vertical
aquilo foi algo que preencher um modelo
de negócio novo que se tornou
insustentável ea partir dessa inovação
gerada e com muita coragem através de
investimento próprio do próprio lemanski
mais de mil empresas hoje em dia criam
seus próprios modelos de negócio junto
ao espaço ao que chamam elas the new
space
então vocês lembram que comecei a
palestra falando a ideia que os países
queriam tocar o espaço isso hoje em dia
inverteu a lógica atual é como eu
consigo tocar problemas reais que a
gente tem no planeta terra através do
espaço e essa inversão
como conseguiu criar uma oportunidade
para o empreendedorismo em turismo
espacial é o astro empreendedorismo de
forma muito mais democrática e hoje em
dia diversos países que não têm nenhuma
história junto ao espaço começa a ter
algumas empresas trabalhando junto ao
espaço
mas que tipo de oportunidade é essa
então eu trouxe aqui 11 slides mostrando
diversas frentes que a gente trabalha
hoje em dia junto ao espaço que vai de
realidade virtual para fazer treinamento
por exemplo de manutenção de uma estação
espacial
eu criar uma missão análoga na terra
vamos ver lá no deserto de utah
simulando como se estivesse vivendo em
marte eu colocar embaixo a órbita
terrestre próxima a yas 400 quilômetros
da superfície constelação de satélites
para tirar foto telecomunicação a 35 mil
quilômetros e coisas que vão cada vez
mais além de uma palavra que
provavelmente vai ficar bem recorrente
nosso cotidiano que a economia se lunar
que a idéia de como eu posso fazer uso
dos recursos entre a terra ea lua a nasa
recentemente anunciou 20 missões para os
próximos 10 anos para fazer uso da lua
ea idéia é realmente ter a lua como um
agente importante da economia espacial
onde vai poder coletar energia minerais
metais valiosos e quem sabe fazer
manufaturas avançadas uma gravidade que
tem aí um oitavo da gravidade terrestre
é muito mais fácil locomover materiais
pesados e teremos materiais e energia em
abundância mas consegue imaginar como é
que isso vai ser grandioso e inclusive
se tornou um trampolim para chegar em
marte chegar em outros sistemas solares
quem sabe daqui a mil anos levando toda
humanidade e obviamente levando à
necessidade da indústria farmacêutica
alimentícia bioquímica e dos e química
dos materiais
então a quantidade de oportunidades que
eu tenho no espaço daqui para frente
sobre essa palavra chamada new space
praticamente abrange todas as atividades
que já existe hoje em dia tem um
cientista indiano que diz uma frase
muito interessante que é todas as
empresas no mundo já são empresas
espaciais
apenas não sabem então cada vez mais a
tecnologia espacial está misturado em
nosso dia a dia e cabe a nós como
brasileiros decidir se queremos ou não
fazer parte desse protagonismo
então a primeira desafio que deixo para
vocês
a idéia de que o rocket science
não é tão difícil quanto as pessoas
imaginam né a gente costuma falar que
isso não é pra mim isso é uma coisa de
cientistas de foguetes na verdade a
gente tem que derrubar essa parede e
cada vez mais tocar essa idéia de que
podemos empreender junto ao espaço
o brasil por exemplo um país aí em
tamanhos continentais poderia ser um
grande a supplier é suprir o mundo com
atividades de serviços de inteligência
artificial para melhorar dados espaciais
gerar novos produtos para mineração
desde o espaço coisa que a gente já faz
melhorar o plantio desde o espaço coisa
que a gente já sabe fazer muito bem na
terra então isso tem várias aptidões
a questão é a gente acreditar que a
gente pode romper essa barreira que é
ter um acesso espaço e cada vez mais
jovens empreendedores
tenha certeza que podem atuar em alguma
economia que vai crescer não exponencial
mas muito além disso
então a idéia é sempre se questionar se
queremos ser atores ou apenas telex
telespectadores dessa nova vertente da
economia que vai atingir o mundo agora
para as próximas décadas
e aí eu deixo como um gatilho inicial a
idéia da base de alcântara é um assunto
está muito em voga agora comentado a
gente tem de fato a melhor base em
questão de posicionamento no mundo ela é
uma pedra preciosa ainda não lapidados a
gente tem muita coisa a desenvolver na
área ainda é de fato uma península não
desenvolvida então você tem uma
necessidade muito grande de levar
recursos desenvolvimento tecnológico
para a região
mas uma vez que você habilita essa
região para lançamento ela pode virar o
primeiro ranking mundial de lançamentos
internacionais e vocês imaginarem que
desde o cantora eu vou ter um espaço
porto que você só não apenas essa baixa
órbita com essas considerações satélites
mas você sa a lua e quem sabe uma nova
civilização que vai viver em marte então
eu deixo aqui pra vocês esse desafio
como brasileiros para não deixar essa
chama pagar de acreditar que o brasil
dentro das suas aptidões pode fazer
parte disso contar pra vocês têm uma
grande jóia irmãos que é uma base que é
melhor base do mundo e que ela pode ser
o vetor inicial que vai puxar diversas
outras atividades empresariais deixar o
desafio que aqui são carlos por ser uma
cidade altamente ligar até
elogia que o grande formação de grandes
pessoas pode se transformar também um
pólo que vai prestar serviços e
desenvolvimento tecnológico não acho que
dentro do novo lar ele vai fazer um foco
nenhum foco regra aqui dentro não tem
espaço pra isso mas eu posso fazer uma
startup que eu vou usar a inteligência
artificial e melhorar o entendimento de
dados que vão ajudar a agricultura no
brasil por exemplo essa minha palestra
para vocês
obrigado a isso
[Aplausos]
[Música]